the nevada is getting warmer and a lot
of companies are in hiring mode because
there's more folks coming here for to be
in the resorts during the summer in the
spring there are job fairs almost every
week as they try and fill up those
positions bianca holman is live this
morning with ways to get the job you
might be after bianca good morning to
you hey good morning john so while
tourism is big business all year round
warmer weather means big bucks for our
properties here in las vegas but they
need help and that means hiring enough
staff we spoke with amy matthews from
nevada association of employers it's an
organization that's been around since
1938 helping businesses solve those hr
problems matthew says some employers are
having trouble filling roles because
people have found gigs and other ways to
make ends meet
i've seen great success
in food and beverage quite frankly
servers are coming back bartenders
bottle girls atmosphere models those
seem to be easier to staff where we're
seeing some of the trouble is in the
trades
you know on ac
installers and you know handyman type
rolls roofers dry wallers
of course that's some great news for
those who are looking for seasonal work
but if you have room to again get
another degree or get some training
there are opportunities out there like
she said like she shared in the trades
and so also based on a survey by the
organization job seekers not only want
competitive pay but they want positive
company culture and recognition so
coming up in the next sci-fi we're going
to hear from a staffing agency with some
tips on how to nail that job if you're
looking bianca holmen live local now
thanks